In 2014, two years after
they first started dating,
mum and David
left the house.
Nobody knew
where they'd gone.
When Sandra left,
I didn't think that'd be
the last time
that me or my children
would see her.
I went back into the house
to get the house ready
for sale.
I was completely horrified
and shocked to see
that on the master bedroom
there was a huge,
industrial size padlock.
That's the kind of lock
you have
on an outside
garage or a locker.
The door would give way
before the lock
would give way.
That is to keep a person in
or out of that room.
There was newspaper.
Completely covered the whole
window in its entirety.
So no one on the outside
could see through what was
happening inside this room.
I just think it's very
disturbing and sinister
that you would go to
the extremes to
A. Block the inside of
the house from outside
and B. Put a lock
of that sub--
A substantial lock
inside the house.
I was surprised of the mail
that was at the house.
There was absolutely
every single bill
and red letter
of final demand
and court summons
that you could imagine.
There's so many
letters here.
Bills and electricity
company.
From the phone company.
From the local
borough council.
Penalty for a parking fine,
tax credits where they're
recovering the money back.
Credit card details.
More parking fines.
Here's one about
the mortgage company.
So, the mortgage hadn't been
paid for many, many months.
Wow.
Sandra didn't have an
overdraft or a credit card
before she knew him.
So, this sad state
of financial affairs,
in my opinion, has all
been brought on by David.
The car that your mum
and David had been driving,
finance on the car not paid.
You're talking about
£35,000 car.
It was top of the line.
The car was a present
for my mum
but financed in her name.
Affectively given a car
she had to pay for.
He always told us
that he was doing
very well for himself
and, you know,
buying flash cars,
having, you know,
expensive watches
and looking through this,
it was all faked.
My mum was an only child.
She was very close
with her parents.
My nan and grandad,
both sadly passed away,
and my mum didn't turn up
to their funerals.
It was so out of character,
but deep down I knew
she wasn't gonna come.
I haven't seen my mum
in seven years.
There has been some contact,
normally
on a withheld number.
If I want to call her,
they don't pick up.
And, in my belief,
the conversations
have all been scripted.
Just feels like
I'm speaking to a robot.
To this day I don't actually
know where she is.
I mean...
She's never once allowed me
to know where she lives.
What's that?
My mum was a loving,
caring woman.
And it just seems that
there's someone there
pulling the strings.
I believe the person behind
all of this is Freegard.